Let's take a second to step back and look at the steps we've gone through over
the past few quizzes to move from f of x, to f inverse of x. First, we change
variable names from f of x to y, just to make our manipulations a little bit
easier. Then we did something that's generally not legal when we're modifying
equations. We switch the positions of x and y in our equation. This is a really
important step, because it's in this step, that we're actually switching from
the original function to the inverse function. After that, we rearrange our
variables once more, so that y was by itself on one side. Then since we know
this is the inverse function. To make that clear, we change the name of y to f
inverse of x. Showing its relationship with the original equation we started
out with. I think it would be worth it to have a bit more practice finding the
inverses of functions. So let's do that, I've written three functions here for
you, f of x equals x plus 1, g of x equals one fourth times x minus 9 and h of
x equals x cubed. For each of these functions, I'd like you to find its
inverse. If you're having trouble remembering what to do and why, then please
go back and just watch the past few videos, or just review the beginning of
this quiz.